foreign The Raid began in the early
hours of Monday morning
Israeli forces entered Janine refugee
camp and a fierce firefighter workout
the Israeli Army described it as a
massive exchange of Fire
during the raid a Palestinian civilians
were killed including a 15 year old his
father remembered him as a polite
teenager
anytime I asked him for something he
always said yes he was decent polite
respectful but his problem was that the
moment the Israeli Army raided he ran
towards them he wanted to die after his
friend homo was killed the death of his
friend was very painful for him
in a rare move Palestinian Fighters
planted an improvised explosive device
at the entrance to the camp and this was
a moment when the armored Israeli
vehicle drove over it
[Music]
Israeli helicopter gunships then fired
missiles into the camp in a bid to
extract the soldiers in the vehicle one
Israeli soldier was injured it's the
first time Israel has used helicopter
gunships for an attack inside the
occupied West Bank in more than 20 years
Israeli forces also fired at the local
hospital where the injured were to
arrive and waiting journals were
gathered the Palestinian Ambulance
Service says its ambulances were also
blocked from entering the camp the
Palestine Liberation Organization is
convening a meeting with the Palestinian
president and all of the factions to
formulate a response to this latest
attack it's also calling for the
International Community to step in and
try and bring a halt to these now near
nightly raids Imran Khan Al Jazeera West
Jerusalem
Abrahim is in the occupied West Bank
what more can you tell us about what's
happening now what we're hearing is that
the Israeli forces are withdrawing or
have withdrawn
yes we can confirm that Israeli forces
have completely withdrawn from the
Janine refugee camp and we can hear the
sounds of Palestinians marching at the
outskirts of the refugee camp mainly we
have five Palestinians who were killed
in this raid so we are expecting the
funeral processions to take place now
after the Israeli forces have left the
refugee camp after a 10 hour raid where
in which we've seen a lot of injuries
we're talking about 91 Palestinians more
than 20 of them in critical conditions
including a minor so it is a tense
situation here there's a lot of anger
and frustration amongst Palestinians
they say that Israel comes in attacks
Palestinians and gets away with it I
don't know if you can hear the sounds
now
we can Knitter we absolutely can and we
can see very distinctly what your
cameraman is showing us if people
walking down the street although I can't
make out
um
where the crowd is going how did this
begin
so usually these crowds take the bodies
of those Palestinians who were killed
for their parents for final farewell
before they're laid to rest this all
started when the Israeli forces have
raided the Janine refugee camp in the
early hours of the morning now according
to the Israeli Army the aim was to
arrest two Palestinians they believed
they were suspected of carrying out
attacks now what happened that is
Palestinians used detonation or
explosive devices that have detonated
that have affected and injured soldiers
as well as damaging armored vehicles
this is something that was alarming to
the Israelis it took them an hour to
take the soldiers and evacuate them to
the hospital it took them one hour to do
so and hours to take the vehicles out so
it was definitely an unusual scene here
something that's pretty notable for all
of this who you know look at this
regularly especially if you who covers
these raids in the West Bank very
regularly is the weapons that were used
on both sides frankly an explosive
device that was set by Palestinian
militants as I understand it and then
helicopters on the Israeli side firing
Rockets into a refugee camp was was all
that and the level of Firepower
surprising to Unita
well the fact that they've used the
explosions and the bombs from
helicopters this is something we haven't
seen in nearly 20 years here in Janine
it was a scene of a battle in 2002
during what's known here as the second
Palestinian antifada where Israel used
Shoppers to drop bombs on Palestinians
so that was definitely an unusual scene
now as uh to explosive devices
Palestinians use that often hear
engineering basically to kind of prevent
the Israelis forces from entering the
camp but it was interesting the fact
that they were able to obstruct the work
of five vehicles and injure those inside
them so as far as Palestinians here are
concerned they're considering this a
success for the Palestinian resistance
and this is kind of why Israel has
escalated what is used to or what could
have been a regular arrest raid to a 10
hour on battle
Nita Ibrahim reporting from Janine in
the occupied West Bank thank you to you
and your team for your reporting
Janine has been at the heart of
Palestinian resistance against the
illegal occupation by Israel after the
1967 war the city in the northern West
Bank came under Israel's control an
estimated 14 000 Palestinians live in
the Janine refugee camp you just saw
what it looked like there during the
second intifada Israel waged a 10-day
military campaign by air and land to
crush a Palestinian Uprising in that
camp nearly 60 Palestinians were killed
the camp now has one of the highest
rates of unemployment and poverty in the
occupied West Bank Palestinian armed
resistance there is increasing as Israel
Israel denies freedom of movement and
continues to raid the camp
let's bring in nibal farsak on this
year's media and communication officer
at the Palestine red crescent she joins
us today from Ramallah thanks for being
on the show share with us if you will
what happened from your perspective how
you first became aware of the raid and
then what your team saw when they
arrived
yes it was such a very hard day for all
Palestinians and for our Medical Teams
who work on the ground to save lives of
Palestinian people Israeli occupation
forces attacked four prcs ambulances
during their conducting Duty engineering
they were directly targeted with live
emanation causing material damage to the
structure and the glass of the
ambulances themselves one of the
ambulances was also had by a military
vehicle before it was shot by the
occupation forces causing damage to the
to the ambulance and it was taken out of
service due to the attack
can I jump in there for just a second I
want to make sure I heard you crystal
clear you say the ambulances of the red
crescent were deliberately targeted is
that right
yes this is right for ambulances were
directly targeted by gunshots
um during
um conducting duties engineering one of
our ambulances was also had by a
military vehicle and went out of service
due to the attack at the same time our
Medical Teams were denied access and
delayed access to the wound and injured
people who who they're in a very severe
conditions need for our urgent help and
urgent medical services also one of the
ambulances was threatened by the Israeli
soldiers and the EMTs who were in the
ambulance were taken out of the
ambulance and uh I received for a while
with that from the Israeli soldiers who
I mean stop them from conducting their
duties at the same time the numbers of
injuries were so much High our team
could only deal with around 43 injuries
this is from early morning uh 4 45 in
the morning so till 3 P.M we dealt with
around
um as I mentioned 43 Anders and
evacuated two murders including 27
gunshots once and a chart now once most
of the injuries as you mentioned it was
dangerous because it was targeted toward
the upper parts of the body
when you say that your teams were denied
access to people who needed treatment
you described a little bit what that
looks like but then you also said that
at some point you were able to access uh
the injured so what does that look like
at some point Israeli soldiers allowed
the red crescent ambulances to move
forward is that right
yes yes because in some cases there was
a tool a totally you know delay of
access and others as I mentioned like
one of our ambulances were stopped and
the EMTs were ascertained by Israeli
Soldiers with their guns they threatened
the empty empties
um and stopped uh let them take out take
the take out the empties from the
ambulance and stop them from conducting
their duties there was a great delay um
and the stopping of our Medical Teams
from providing the medical services for
the injuries but we were able finally to
arrive at some injuries that's why we
only succeeded in arriving 43
um injuries uh that's the one that the
prcs medical teams were able to deal
with however
um other injuries might be transferred
by a private Vehicles
who were able to transfer the injuries
but the total number of injuries where
we can we are able to provide medical
services where around 43
um 43 entries and we at the prcs views
um this with a very great concern uh
because these uh repeated violations
stopped our Medical Teams from
conducting their medical duties in the
ground and this is against the
international
humanitarian law which emphasized the
rules and and Norms of the endangering
the lives of Medical Teams Nebo thank
you for joining us on the program today
as we try and get more detail and shed
some light on what happened today in
Janine
Palestine red crescent thank you